est ce que quelqu'un qui reconnaît cette
image
ceci est un fromage un fromage qui était
dans l'espace pour être spécifique
c'était une charge utile qui a été mise
en orbite par une compagnie qui
s'appelle spacek ce fondé par nos
masques et pour faire leurs preuves
spacek sont développés un lanceur falcon
qui a quand même réussi sa mission et
mettre un satellite en orbite
après trois échecs donc la quatrième
tentative a été réussie et le coût total
de ce projet à peu près 90 millions $ et
pour donner crédit spacek s'est quand
même l'entreprise en ce moment qui
offrent les meilleurs clients en termes
de lancements
donc c'est quand même un problème dans
un monde où on est de plus en plus
dépendants de l'information et du big
data
il est absolument fondamental qu'on a
accès à l'espace de façon plus régulière
mais surtout de façon plus abordable
ça va nous permettre de connecter des
gens qui n'ont pas accès à internet
ça va améliorer leur vie de point de vue
équité et progrès ça va également nous
permettre de mieux comprendre la
problématique du changement climatique
qui est une grosse problématique
actuellement on va pouvoir optimiser
leurs ressources
ça va également nous permettre de mieux
gérer l'agriculture il ya beaucoup de
choses qu'on peut faire un compromis le
réussir d'accès à l'information qui
provient de l'espace mais avant de
commencer
laissez moi vous parler d'une des
problématiques dans l'industrie
à
faire des fusées c'est difficile c'est
très très difficile et ça je peux vous
en parler un tout petit peu aujourd'hui
depuis à peu près deux ans j'ai eu la
très belle opportunité de faire de la
recherche à polytechnique avec un
professeur jean robert ou un des projets
sur lesquels on travaille et sur la
propulsion fusée c'est pour réduire les
coûts en fait c'est une nouvelle
technologie pour nous permettre de
réduire les coûts d'accès à l'espace et
depuis 2011
j'ai rejoint renault un groupe étudiant
qui a pour but de concevoir développer
et fabriquer dancing fusée une nouvelle
fusée à chaque année afin de participer
à une compétition aux états unis
cette compétion da c'est pas une
compétition de qui va le plus vite ou
qui va le bureau c'est une compétition
de précisions donc on doit se rendre à
une altitude en particulier une attitude
prédéterminé avec le plus de précision
possible dans ce cas là c'est d'y
militer pour la catégorie de base et 30
nuque et pour la catégorie avancée pour
cette année avec hornos on développe
absolument toutes les composantes
on développe les fuselages on développe
aussi l'avionique
on développe absolument tout et quand
j'ai rejoint l'équipe
il était absolument impensable pour nous
mais impensable qu'on a un moteur qui
fonctionne parce que s'est achevée très
complexe mais après trois ans de
recherche de développement et après
beaucoup de travail acharné et grâce à
la contribution d'une équipe tout à fait
formidable
nous avons ici cet exploit de l'année
dernière en octobre
on a fait nos premiers tests c'est un
succès et on espère dans quelques mois
avoir un moteur fonctionnel pour qu'on
puisse incorporé dans notre fusée pour
cette compétition de cette année et pour
vous dire on a quand même remporté cette
compétition trois ans de suite en 2012
et 2014
on retient les deux records de précision
dans les deux catégories
donc je pense qu'on simple qu'est ce
qu'on fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la question qui revient toujours c'est
pourquoi est ce que ça coûte si cher de
lancer des fusées pourquoi ça coûte si
cher d'aller dans l'espace
les coûts sont quand même variable d'une
fusée à d'autres mais ça reste quand
même quelque chose qui est accessible à
tous en fait au-delà des structures et
au delà de l'avionique et des systèmes
au sol c'est vraiment larchitecture du
système de propulsion qui impose et coup
et qu impose beaucoup de choses par la
suite
ces moteurs sont quand même assez
complexe par contre le fonctionnement
d'une fusée en principe est quand même
très très simples comme on sait tous
puisqu'il pas d'oxygène dans l'espace
nous avons besoin d'apporter de
l'oxygène pour nous pour que la fusée
puisse fonctionner
donc nous avons un occident à carburant
les deux réagissent ensemble sacrés de
la température ça en fait c'est une
combustion sacré d'énergie thermique
cette énergie thermique est convertie en
énergie mécanique on a de la poussée et
c'est aussi simple que ça mais c'est
vraiment l'ingénierie derrière qui est
très complexe
c'est l'aspect technique qui est très
complexe il ya plusieurs options il ya
plusieurs options qui s'offrent à nous
nous pouvons avoir un occident solide et
un carburant solide
ça ressemble un peu à un gros feu
d'artifice c'est ce que la nasa avait
utilisé pour les booster en fait c'est
un peu ce qui ressemble à des crayons
autour de la navette spatiale
si motorola sont les plus sympas
développer et c'est aussi le moteur qui
donne beaucoup de pousser dans une très
courte merde de période de perte de
temps et c'est à peu près ça qu'on a
besoin puis c'est exactement pour ça
qu'on développe les fusées une autre
option ça serait d'utiliser un occident
liquide est un carburant liquide
ces moteurs sont de loin les plus
utilisés en industrie c'est aussi les
plus complexes mais aussi les plus
performants au delà du cou et au delà de
la performance faut quand même garder en
compte qu'il a certaines problématiques
qu'on n'a pas réussi à résoudre pour ses
moteurs là entre autres l'instabilité de
combustion donc on doit faire beaucoup
de tests et ça augmente les coûts de
développement de le coût de tout le
processus en fait faut garder en tête
actuellement les fusées à part quelques
exceptions près elle ne sont pas
réutilisables donc pour mettre un
satellite en orbite
la fusée décolle le satellite est mis en
orbite le carburant et l'occident sont
consommés
et la fusée s'écrase dans l'océan ça
s'arrête là donc ces belles merveilles
de technologie sur lesquels on met
beaucoup d'heures de travail et beaucoup
d'argent se retrouvent dans les fonds
des océans avec les poissons
c'est un peu comme si chaque fois que
vous voulez partir en vacances en europe
on va dire plutôt que d'acheter un
billet d'avion
vous devez acheter de l'avion au complet
je dois pas de tous les billets d'avion
non c'est vraiment un avion que vous
devez faire faire sur mesure faire
concevoir fabriquer développer tester et
certifier juste pour que vous puissiez
partir en vacances à chaque fois à
chaque fois et à chaque fois mais
maintenant si on pouvait passer de 100 à
ça ceci est un moteur hybride
dans le cas de cette image le carburant
est sous forme solide et l'occident et
sous forme unique et le carburant c'est
la partie transparente qui brûle et
l'occident c'est ce qu'un objectif par
le tube ses moteurs nord ont été
développées dans les années 30 en union
soviétique
il ya eu un regain d'intérêt dans les
années 90 grâce à la découverte d'un
nouveau type de carburant par des
chercheurs en verser 5 fraude ces
moteurs offrent les avantages des deux
technologies qu'on a couvert
précédemment ils sont simples
collimateur collimateur solide mais
offre aussi des performances qui sont
assez comparables au moteur l'équipe
un des avantages notables et qui en fait
vraiment une option intéressante c'est
vraiment le coup le coût de
développement de ses moteurs un peu
moins élevé que les autres
cette technologie n'a encore un peu de
chemin à faire pour que ça puisse
propulser des fusées quotidien pour que
ça puisse propulsé diffusé
quotidiennement dans l'espace par contre
ça devient de plus en plus une option
intéressante étant donné l'aspect
plastique ou rich green scène avec leur
dernière entreprise vos jeans
galactiques ont utilisé un moteur qui
est similaire pour leur dernière étape
donc je peux vous dire avec certitude
que le potentiel de cette technologie
peut vraiment faire en sorte que ça
devienne une innovation de rupture
imaginez maintenant un monde où aller
passer des vacances sont pour aller sur
la lune
passé le jour de noël où on pourrait
aller dans l'espace pour une fin de
semaine pour vous rappeler ça ressemble
à quoi
et pour ceux qu'ils ont une bonne
tolérance au risque
eh bien vous pourrez aller sur mars
passé quelques jours découvrir un peu et
vous pourriez revenir pour nous en
parler
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui va
arriver et ce n'est qu'une histoire de
temps et s'il ya une chose que je veux
que vous retenez de la présentation
aujourd'hui c'est que ça va arriver et
un jour quelqu'un de vous aura
l'opportunité d'aller dans l'espace
le coût de lancement sera tellement bas
que ce serait une possibilité
et si une deuxième chose que j'aimerais
que vous retenu c'est que ce sera des
entreprises montréalaises qui vont faire
la différence
merci
[Applaudissements]